bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
les dirigeants du monde entier sont à
New York aux Nations Unies les chefs
d'État enchaînent les discours à la
tribune de l'Assemblée générale annuelle
la guerre en Ukraine la crise climatique
ou encore l'insécurité alimentaire ont
des conséquences mondiales mais dans un
monde de plus en plus fragmenté nous
nous réunissons un moment de grands
péril pour le monde à lancer Antonio
guteres secrétaire général de l'ONU Joe
Biden devrait s'exprimer demain ainsi
que volodimear Zelinski par vidéo
Emmanuel Macron dans la soirée les
absents de cette grand-messe sont
Vladimir Poutine et sea Jinping c'est
sergueil lavrof le chef de la diplomatie
russe ce qui fera le déplacement alors
que peut faire l'ONU pour résoudre des
conflits comme la guerre en Ukraine
alors que la Russie est un membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité que
peut faire l'ONU pour faire respecter
les droits de l'homme en Chine alors que
la Chine est un membre permanent des
Nations Unies que peut faire l'ONU pour
faire appliquer les accords sur le
climat le multilatéralisme est-il encore
considéré ou n'est-il plus
utopie dans un monde fracturé et bien on
va en débattre avec mes invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés ces Dick ah
bah bonsoir journaliste et écrivain
auteur de Miley Sahel notre Afghanistan
à nous c'est à impact édition et ses
sorties donc en 2022 merci d'être avec
nous en face de vous Michel Duclos
bonsoir diplomate conseiller spécial à
l'Institut Montaigne votre dernier
article la guerre en Ukraine comment la
Russie a perdu l'Occident et publié dans
la revue Commentaire bienvenue à vous
ensuite Frédéric jolyt avec nous
porte-parole du CICR Comité
international de la à Croix-Rouge
bienvenue à vous également tout de suite
direction New York où on retrouve notre
envoyé spécial Mark peyrolman Marc
bonsoir vous êtes devant l'immeuble des
Nations unies sur liste River c'est à
peu près la 40e à New York à Manhattan
les discours ont démarré il y a eu Jair
bolsonaro il y a eu un Macky Sall l'ONU
sert-elle encore à quelque chose
oui bonjour Stéphanie c'est vrai que
autant le temps est ensoleillé ici à New
York autant l'atmosphère est très sombre
dans l'immeuble de verre derrière moi
parce que les problèmes se multiplient
alors on sait que l'ONU souffre déjà des
déséquilibres dénoncés notamment par les
pays en développement le fait qu'il
n'est pas de réels voient au chapitre au
Conseil de sécurité mais là c'est vrai
que le Conseil de sécurité est fracturé
il y a la Russie il y a la Chine d'un
côté il y a la guerre en Ukraine il y a
les tensions sur Taïwan et le secrétaire
général de l'ONU que j'ai interviewé il
y a deux jours tente de garder cet
équilibre précaire mais c'est vrai qu'il
constate cette paralysie même cette
fracture alors oui il y a eu la guerre
froide là il y a une sorte de nouvelle
guerre froide qui s'installe et qui
paralyse le système onuséen on le voit
évidemment avec la guerre en Ukraine
mais on l'a vu déjà dans le passé il y a
pas si longtemps avec la guerre en Syrie
on la voit on le voit sur des questions
comme la crise énergétique la crise
alimentaire la crise climatique l'ONU se
contente d'être une tribune comme ces
jours-ci où il y a des appels oui il
faut coopérer oui le monde multilatéral
est la seule solution au problème de
notre planète mais c'est vrai que le
système est paralysé et beaucoup pensent
que peut-être de cette crise ukrainienne
sortira une réelle volonté de réforme
qui a jusqu'ici fait défaut merci Marc
Marc perleman donc en direct de New York
on va tout de suite écouter Macky Sall
le président sénégalais qui s'est
exprimé justement déjà à la tribune des
Nations Unies
il est temps de vaincre les réticences
et de construire le narratif qui
persiste à confiner l'Afrique à la marge
de cercle décisionnel il est temps de
faire droit à la juste et légitime
revendications africaine sur la réforme
du Conseil de sécurité
tels que refléter dans le consensus
dans le même esprit
je rappelle notre demande
d'octroi d'un siège à l'Union africaine
au sein du G20
pour que l'Afrique puisse enfin se faire
représenter là où se prennent les
décisions qui engagent un milliard 400
millions d'Africains
Macky Sall il est tout de même à cette
tribune est-ce que ça sert encore à
quelque chose l'ONU cette tribune déjà
oui je pense que la revendication est
tout à fait légitime et le récurrente
chez les Africains la gouvernance
mondiale telle qu'elle est conçue
aujourd'hui est totalement inadapté
c'est la gouvernance mondiale qui sort
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale avec les
vainqueurs qui ont chacun un siège au
niveau du Conseil de sécurité elle n'est
plus adaptée à notre conseil à notre
contexte d'aujourd'hui il faut
absolument qu'elle évolue on a tenté à
côté de stratégies pour corriger en
créant le jeu 20 en créant d'autres
structure mais elles sont totalement
inadaptées et la revendication qui est
portée par Macky Sall et de toute de SL
de tout un continent qui vaut
aujourd'hui 1,4 milliards de personnes
qui pensent pas le droit de participer
aux décisions qui le concernent et qui
concerne le reste Michel Duclos du coup
elle est obsolète cette tenue ou juste
impuissante
moi je dirais qu'elle est surtout
paralysée
par ce que vous appelez la fracturation
et donc surtout par la polarisation
entre le
Russe Chine et les Occidentaux et ce qui
concerne l'Afrique et d'autres je pense
que leur rôle c'est de s'unir pour
réclamer que cette polarisation cesse de
toute valorisée mais vous l'avez
vous-même indiqué il faut se souvenir
que pendant la guerre froide c'était
comme ça et qu'en réalité la période
pendant laquelle le Conseil de sécurité
a travaillé de manière efficace a été
brève ça a été les années 90 le début
des années 2000 mais à partir de la
chute du mur de Berlin en fait pour
faire un peu simple
ou la Russie a joué le jeu et et sur la
serre irakienne les Américains n'ont pas
joué le jeu puisqu'ils se sont
affranchis de toute autorisation du
Conseil de sécurité
et à partir de l'affaire syrienne les
Russes se sont enfermés dans une idée
attitude
négative systématique par la pratique du
veto et donc c'est pas parce qu'il y a
cette modalité de quand même de
fonctionnement qu'il y ait au Conseil de
sécurité avec ses cinq membres
permanents qui doivent décider de tout à
l'unanimité il y a ça en plus de la non
représentativité dont par le Macky Sall
les institutions sont le produit de
l'histoire vous avez raison si on a
1945 attribué au monde permanence
système de veto c'est que dans la
Société des nations qui avaient précédé
les Nations Unies il y avait pas de veto
et donc les grandes puissances se sont
retirées donc la condition pour que les
grandes puissances pensions nous à
l'époque
contribuent ou le dieu c'est qu'il y ait
cette sauvegarde alors après peut-être
que elle ne joue pas le jeu oui elles en
ont on envoie les limites aujourd'hui
comme vous le savez la frange pas
défendre la position française je suis
retraité c'est de me dire mais le fait
que la France elle avec le Royaume-Uni
était son reste partisane de
l'élargissement du Conseil y compris il
y a un siège africain je rappelle aussi
que les Africains n'ont pas été capable
de se mettre d'accord sur un sur un
membre permanent unique et donc
demande font une demande qui est plus
difficile à accepter par les autres
Frédéric Joly votre point de vue vous
qui êtes porte-parole du Comité
international de la Croix-Rouge on parle
beaucoup des droits de l'homme alors
effectivement est-ce que l'ONU parvient
à elle sort des rapports il y a eu un
rapport sur les Ouigours il y a des
rapports en Ukraine en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui sur les exactions des Russes
bon le CIC est observateur aux Nations
Unies le CIC gardien du droit
international humanitaire des fameuses
conventions de qui protège les victimes
dans la guerre et que notre
préoccupation principale et ceux de
puissance 60 ans c'est qu'en attendant
que le politique trouve des solutions au
conflit armés et arrivent à régler et
bien qu'il y a un espace humanitaire
suffisant pour permettre notamment aussi
de pouvoir travailler que ce soit en
Ukraine ou que ce soit dans de nombreux
conflits conflits aujourd'hui en Afrique
donc notre positionnement il est en
attendant que le politique règle les
crises il faut bien faire quelque chose
et c'est quelque chose est beaucoup fait
par les humanitaires donc ça veut dire
que vous substituez à des institutions
telles que l'ONU pratique
non mais je pense que par défaut
remplace beaucoup les États qui ont
l'obligation de respecter de faire
respecter en toute circonstances le
droit humanitaire qui protège les
victimes dans la guerre et comme ils le
font peu pas ou mal et bien dans de
nombreuses situations le CIC par défaut
à ce rôle là dans la plupart des
conflits armés d'aujourd'hui on peut en
compter largement plus de 35 alors bien
sûr l'Ukraine la guerre en Ukraine est
au centre une discussion on conseille au
Conseil de sécurité à New York il
devrait y avoir d'ailleurs une réunion
au niveau des ministres des Affaires
étrangères jeudi des référendums vont
être organisés c'est vraiment
l'information de la journée par les pros
russes à Louhans qui a donné ce à Carson
encore asaporigia on va faire un point
en images pour en débattre ensuite
un vote à main levée en petits comité à
l'unanimité les membres de la Chambre
civile de la région de louansk plaid
pour l'instauration d'un référendum sur
le rattachement de la région à la Russie
leur choix en 2014 lors d'un référendum
d'autodétermination nous avons attendu
espéré un second référendum toutes ces
années qui nous permettrait d'intégrer
la Russie
quelques instants plus tard les régions
de doniesk de Kerson deux aporidia dans
le sud l'ont emboîté le pas le scrutin a
été fixé du 23 au 27 septembre prochain
l'issue de ces quatre référendums ne
fait guérir de doute ils interviennent
alors que les troupes russes perdent du
terrain et manque d'hommes et d'armes
Moscou cherche ainsi à sécuriser ses
conquêtes territoriales
tout d'abord
c'est une tentative d'établir les
frontières de ces territoires là où se
trouve la ligne de front
deuxièmement cela donnera à la Russie la
possibilité de présenter les tentatives
ukrainiennes de reprendre ses régions
comme une attaque directe de l'Ukraine
contre la Russie alors la guerre sera
déclarée et il pourrait mener une
mobilisation forcée
la tenue de tel scrutin n'aurait aucune
légitimité démocratique les autorités
prorus veulent calquer ces référendum
sur celui de 2014 qui a permis à la
Russie d'annexer la péninsule
ukrainienne de Crimée un vote qui n'a
pas été reconnu par la communauté
internationale
on voit bien que c'est une riposte bien
sûr de Vladimir Poutine des Russes
l'Ukraine mérite un soutien
international plus large c'est ce
qu'elle dit bankimoun dans une interview
du monde qui est paru aujourd'hui est-ce
que on a l'impression tout de même qu'il
y a une sorte de de
rupture de conflits Nord-Sud justement
dans ce soutien aux Ukrainiens on a vu
que Macky Sall n'avait pas vraiment
soutenu au départ les Ukrainiens il a un
peu changé d'avis sur cette question
ukrainienne la première ministre des
Barbades a dit que les conflits
d'antigré ou en Syrie on en parlait pas
suffisamment alors qu'on ne parlait que
de l'Ukraine est-ce qu'il y a une sorte
de front antioxydant je pense pas qu'on
puisse dire qu'il y a un front
antioxydant mais il y a une volonté de
la part des États y compris de beaucoup
d'États africains de ne pas avoir un
alignement mécanique sur la position
occidentale d'être tout en condamnant
l'entorse au droit international qui est
l'invasion d'un pays l'Ukraine par la
Russie mais de garder de canaux y
compris de Can de communication avec
Poutine le président Macky Sall s'est
déplacé à Moscou
à rencontrer le président Poutine mais
l'Union africaine a organisé une vision
conférence pour écouter le président de
ski et cette position je pense à la fois
qui n'est pas une position d'aliments
mécanique il y a eu beaucoup
d'incompréhension par exemple il y a eu
35 pays en le 2 mars 2022 lorsque au
devant l'Assemblée générale des Nations
unies il y a eu le vote contre
l'invasion de l'Ukraine 35 pays
africains seulement on prépare au vote
et sur le 35 pays 17
et je pense que c'est tout à fait
légitime de ne pas avoir une position
totalement mécanique de s'aligner
automatiquement sur la position de
l'Union européenne les pays africains
ont je pense de façon légitime la
possibilité de dire sur telle position
on n'est pas d'accord par exemple sur la
question des sanctions les pays
africains contre la Russie les pays
africains n'ont pas un aliment mécanique
sur l'Union européenne et je pense que
ça fait partie justement de la volonté
de ne pas avoir un monde unipolaire ou
c'est seulement l'Occident qui dicterait
des choses qu'il faut faire et ça vous
pouvez le dire à l'ONU les pieds
africains à l'assemblée générale et je
pense que c'est c'est ça un B on peut
critiquer l'ONU mais c'est le seul
espace où au niveau de l'assemblée
générale la le Cap Vert a le même droit
que les nations les États-Unis Michel
Duclos elle est tenable cette position
est-ce que vous voyez quelque sorte de
rupture Nord-Sud oui là aussi pardon je
vois ça en perspective le clivage
Nord-Sud a existé depuis toujours si je
puis dire
j'avais l'impression personnellement
qu'il avait été surmonté au moment de la
COP 21 à Paris où là tous les pays du
monde quel que soit leur géographie
politique ou autre c'était rendu compte
qu'on était dans le même bateau c'est en
2016 c'était un succès pour le temps
et et là on avait retrouvé une certaine
unité de la planète autour d'objectifs
évident et puis ça s'est effectivement
un peu
effiloché est-ce que Trump
l'Occident n'a pas tenu sa promesse
d'accompagner
l'affaire du covid
s'il était juré telle façon que ça crée
la perception d'une d'une inégalité et
là ce qui est assez extraordinaire c'est
que sur cette affaire on a l'impression
que le clivage Nord-Sud réapparaît vous
avez dit par exemple sur l'Ukraine et
vous avez dit que
zelinsky avait été auditionné par
les chefs d'État de l'Union africaine
c'est vrai il y avait 5 chefs d'État de
l'Union africaine qui ont assisté à sa
conférence donc on voit bien mais on
voit bien là à la différence de l'Europe
il n'y a pas un siège où tous les États
africains se trouvent lorsque il s'est
exprimé il y a des chefs d'État qui sont
venus à Addis-Abeba et tout le monde ne
pouvait pas faire le déplacement il y
avait pas un sommet
le décalage
certains disent émotionnels ou disons
psychologiques pour nous la Russie
commet une horreur
pour beaucoup de pays dans le monde ils
comprennent l'Afrique la Russie commis
une erreur mais après beaucoup d'autres
erreurs commises par l'Occident
erreur contre horreur oui et relativisme
si vous voulez moi personnellement je
vais vous dire ma position personnelle
si j'étais ministre de faire étrangère
je dirais un certain nombre de pays vous
avez condamné l'invasion
américaine en Irak nous aussi et bien
condamné l'invasion
russe de l'Ukraine alors sur les
sanctions on peut être d'accord ou pas
d'accord de toute façon c'est pas
tellement tel ou tel pays africain qui
feront la différence mais il y a
certains pays pour lesquels leur
contribution non et cruciale l'Arabie
Saoudite la Turquie l'Inde je ne suis
pas partisan effectivement que les
européens ou les américains arrivent
avec des gros bâtons mais qu'on fasse
sentir quand même assez pays que c'est
gênant que là mais pourquoi
de non alignée alors erdoa on va
l'écouter d'ailleurs le président
aux Nations Unies justement à New York
au clan
le conflit en Ukraine dépasse le seuil
des 7 mois et nous pensons que la guerre
n'aura pas de vainqueur mais qu'un
processus de pêche juste n'aura pas de
perdant
c'est crucial car nous insistons sur
l'importance de la diplomatie pour
trouver une solution via le dialogue une
bonne fois pour toute
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi nous invitons les parties
au Forum de la diplomatie et nous
appelons à ceux qui s'emboule deviennent
un interlocuteur pour un processus de
réconciliation
par exemple air de one bon mais pourquoi
pas je suis d'accord pour qu'il y ait
des gens qui parlent à la Russie c'est
pas c'est pas ça le problème le problème
c'est que Emmanuel Macron aussi
viennent de franchir à seuil quand même
très important puisque ils annexent une
partie d'un pays voisin cette annexation
d'un pays voisins va leur donner un
prétexte pour dire il y a une ligne
rouge donc si continue leur attaque sur
notre territoire tout est permis y
compris l'escalade la plus la plus
violente bon si on veut que des pays
cessent de se comporter de cette manière
il faut que la communauté internationale
dans son ensemble condamnent
beaucoup sur le terrain qui a vraiment
une sorte de clivage nord-sud qui s'est
recréée dans le cadre de ce conflit en
Ukraine et on va revenir sur le
référendum bien sûr peut-être c'est un
peu difficile à commenter mais on a
brutalement redécouvert avec la crise en
Ukraine que finalement le CICR depuis
très longtemps travaillé beaucoup dans
des conflits assez éloignés finalement
les plus proches étaient mais y compris
dans le temps c'était la guerre en
Europe en exiguslavie mais sinon ça se
passe en Afrique en Asie en Afghanistan
en Asie centrale etc la brutalement on
s'est retrouvé confronté à effectivement
un conflit majeur ou tout l'arsenal du
droit international humanitaire
s'applique qui nous permet de pouvoir
discuter avec tous les belligérant
d'avoir accès aux prisonniers des deux
côtés d'essayer de pouvoir passer des
lignes de front pour apporter de
l'assistance ça je crois qu'on l'a
découvert et que on est longtemps resté
finalement sur des conflits qui étaient
beaucoup plus éloignés y compris
peut-être même de notre de notre culture
et on est en train de brutalement
découvrir quelque chose j'aurais aussi
signalé et alors c'est la première fois
peut-être que on voit un conflit avec
une telle intensité médiatique justifiée
de par son ampleur mais aussi la
profusion des médias sociaux et je crois
que c'est véritablement une première en
terme de cocktail et de gestion de la
formation y compris pour nous pour que
l'humanitaire soit acceptée sur le
terrain pour que l'espace humanitaire
soit respecté on est obligé aussi à la
fois de faire cette pédagogie vers les
médias bien sûr vers tous les
interlocuteurs politiques avec lesquels
on s'adresse au quotidien mais aussi
d'essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe
à travers les réseaux sociaux et ça fait
aussi partie finalement de l'espace
humanitaire qu'il faut pouvoir conquérir
pour pouvoir atteindre les victimes que
nous sommes censés de voir assister
protéger on va écouter Emmanuel Macron
qui s'est exprimé justement sur ces
fameux référendums qui vont être
organisés dans ces différentes régions
ukrainiennes des référendums organisés
par les prorus
ceci n'a pas d'existence légale et donc
il s'agit d'une provocation
supplémentaire qui à nos yeux ne
donnerait lieu à aucune conséquence sur
la position qui est la nôtre la Russie
doit quitter le territoire ukrainien
les armées russes doivent quitter le
territoire ukrainien qui est un
territoire souverain elle doit respecter
les frontières qui sont
internationalement reconnues et alors
même qu'elle a organisé et qu'elle a
créé des fuites massives de population
l'idée même d'organiser des référendums
dans des régions qui ont subi la guerre
les bombardements ou les gens du fuir et
la signature du cynisme
la signature du sinistre donc là
effectivement il faudrait condamner
absolument non il n'y a aucune
hésitation c'est tout à fait clair on
organise pas et de référendum mascarade
comme ça pour donner une sorte de
légitimité juridique à une occupation
sur ce plan il n'y a pas de débat et la
plupart des pays africains
condamneraient sans hésiter cette forme
de mascarade mais il y a d'autres
aspects sur lequel il peut y avoir des
débat mais sur cette question très
précise il n'y a pas l'ombre d'un doute
c'est tout à fait condamnable c'est une
mascarade c'est une politique de fait
pas complique qu'on a vu d'ailleurs dans
d'autres parties du monde au
Proche-Orient ou on occupe un territoire
et on ne le rend plus non ça je pense
que sur ce plan il n'y a aucun débat
est-ce que c'est hasard Michel Duclos
effectivement cette annonce de
référendum est lieu aujourd'hui donc
premier jour de l'assemblée générale
annuelle à l'ONU que Vladimir Poutine
d'ailleurs n'est pas allé à New York
alors qu'il utilise parfois cette
tribune
ce n'est pas hasard
qui ne se fait pas à New York mais qui
se fait là en ce moment à travers ces
référendum non c'est plutôt une marque
de de mépris il est il est allé très
rarement à New York je me demande si la
dernière fois c'était pas en 2015
il faut en trouver mais c'est pas il a
été arrivé d'y aller mais encore une
fois c'est pas ses habitudes et là c'est
clair que depuis un certain nombre
d'années il a fait le choix délibéré
d'organiser une contre société à la
société internationale et le dernier
exemple c'est cette réunion de sa
marquant de de l'OCS et manifestement il
n'aime pas il veut il veut déstabiliser
ses institutions nées de la Charte des
gestionnaires cette réunion où il y
avait Vladimir Poutine mais également le
Premier ministre indien que vous citez
donc à sa marquante cette institution
qui s'appelle d'ailleurs me semble-t-il
organisme de Shanghai est-ce qu'elle
pourrait concurrencer l'ONU parce
qu'elle vise est-ce qu'elle vit
justement en concurrencer l'ONU non elle
vise à concurrencer le G20 ou le G7 et
puisque vous appréciez leur vie
commentaire j'avais publié justement en
2015 un article sur les puissances
émergentes et la politique mondiale et à
l'époque j'étais très frappé de se
regroupement qui avait créé ou suscité
les Russes qui s'appelait les Brix qui
était un moyen très astucieux pour eux
on se mêlant aux Indiens au chinois aux
Africains du Sud et au Brésilien de ce
refaire une virginité et là les briques
sont atteints un peu leur limite et on a
l'impression qu'avec l'OCS il crée
quelque chose
les mêmes membres créent quelque chose
d'un peu différent dans le même esprit
simplement cette fois c'est évidemment
les Chinois qui ont pris le bâton du
leadership c'est ça peut-être la
différence justement Frédéric Jolivot
qui est justement au CICR est-ce qu'on
peut dire tout de même que l'ONU gagne à
être connu sur je dirais les les procès
par exemple où est-ce que le tribunal
international de l'ONU est trop contesté
par exemple par les pays du Sud parce
que là en ce moment il y a des
procédures évidemment on parlait d'isium
mais il y a également eu des exactions à
bout de chat pardon et donc il y a des
procédures judiciaires en cours est-ce
qu'on peut dire que là l'ONU pour être
efficace écoutez c'est surtout à l'ONU
de répondre à cette question enfin c'est
quand même de constater que le système
international sur la justice
internationale et pas très bien encore
organisé on voit bien que la Cour Pénale
même si depuis 98 ça a été une immense
avancée mais il y a aussi par exemple
beaucoup d'États qui ne sont pas membres
et parmi les plus puissants qui sont
toujours pas partis au statut de la Cour
pénale internationale et donc déjà ce
déséquilibre pose un comptablement un
problème sur sur l'équité finalement ou
sur comment dirais-je l'addition que
pourrait apporter cette cette justice là
nous mais on peut se dire que Vladimir
Poutine pour un jour justement de voir
répondre de ces crimes grâce à un
tribunal international de ce type il
faut espérer que la justice
internationale s'améliore s'enrichissent
et puis se punir tous ceux qui sont
soupçonnés d'avoir commis des crimes
mais malheureusement on voit que les
exemples de données particulièrement
avec la CPI de la cour pénal
international vers laquelle il avait
énormément d'espoir et bien on voit bien
qu'elle LATAM malheureusement ses
limites et pour autant il faut continuer
à encourager qu'il puisse y avoir des
moyens des instruments de dissuasion
pour prévenir aussi les crimes de guerre
c'est ici un travail dans plus de 35
conflits armés actifs et on voit bien
malheureusement en tant que gardien des
Conventions de Genève et bien que c'est
violation sont quotidiennes même si à
d'autres endroits ce droit là est aussi
au minimum respecté avoir accès aux
détenus pour le CICR par exemple fait
que les puissances détentrices fallait
puissance qui ont des détenus et bien
respectent une partie de droit
malheureusement c'est tout un arsenal
qu'il faudrait respecter non je pense
que
il y a une sorte de retour de la
manivelle quand même les mêmes qui
aujourd'hui couvrent le multilatéralisme
de toutes ses vertus y compris la
justice internationale on contribué à
son affaiblissement les États-Unis par
exemple sur la question de la justice
internationale non seulement ils n'ont
pas adhéré à la Cour pénale
internationale mais ils avaient même ils
sont allés jusqu'à révoquer le visage de
la procureur de la Cour pénale
internationale donc ils ont contribué et
ont entravé toutes les enquêtes que la
Cour pouvait faire qu'il est concerné
donc aujourd'hui cette brèche qu'ils ont
ouverte à contribuer à affaiblir la
justice internationale et c'est pour ça
que à l'époque où il le faisait les gens
le mettaient en garde donc il y a une
sorte de perte de crédibilité oui il y a
elle m'affaiblissement de la justice
internationale que l'on réclame
aujourd'hui du fait de certains
comportements antérieurs Michel Duclos
est lié aussi au comportement justement
notamment des États-Unis
évidemment
la Cour pénale internationale a
bénéficié à un moment donné d'une
atmosphère favorable dans de la
communauté internationale parce que les
Américains c'était les démocrates
sans vouloir y a des raies on laissait
faire et après il y a une réaction moi
j'étais personnellement à New York quand
on a transféré le Soudan de la Cour
Pénale darfourner à l'international
après des nuits de négociation on a
obtenu que les Américains s'abstiennent
et donc là on a eu l'impression que une
page était tournée mais pas du tout
après il y a eu Trump il y a eu d'autres
incidents et aujourd'hui il y a peu de
pays les pays africains pour d'autres
raisons
n'apprécient pas la Cour pénale
internationale donc finalement il reste
un petit noyau d'Européens qui continue
à soutenir mais là encore c'est ça la
vie internationale il y a des hauts et
des bas moi je ne crois pas qu'il faille
désespérer j'ai cité le Darfour
Omar El Bachir n'a pas été finalement à
La Haye mais il a fini par tomber et
d'ailleurs les autorités soudanaises
vont donner faire des bruits pour dire
qu'ils étaient prêtes ils étaient prêtes
à transférer ce tyran à l'année
quand même un rôle ça joue quand même un
rôle je crois le climat vous en parliez
évidemment de ces accords de Paris on a
l'impression effectivement que là il y
avait eu un accord mondial c'était vrai
après d'exécution bien sûr pose problème
puisque Donald Trump est sorti de la
corde Joe Biden est revenu mais en tout
cas pour Antonio au guteres actuel
secrétaire général de l'ONU et bien
c'est une sorte de cris qu'il a qu'il a
exercé à l'ouverture de cette fameuse
assemblée générale de l'ONU on l'écoute
mais pendant ce temps l'industrie des
énergies fossiles se régale de centaines
de milliards de dollars de subventions
et de bénéfices exceptionnels tandis que
le budget des familles diminue et que
notre planète brûle excellence disons
les choses telles qu'elles sont notre
monde est à cause énergie fossile et il
est temps d'intervenir nous devons
demander des comptes aux entreprises de
combustibles fossiles et à ceux qui les
soutiennent
des solutions politiques vous avez
raison de le souligner vont être trouvés
par les États à travers des enceintes on
ne peut que l'espérer des Nations Unies
est très emblématique de ceux qui
viennent d'être décrit on voit par en
termes de timing d'abord le fait comme
qu'on parle de justice climatique
aujourd'hui c'est important puisque on
est à l'avant veille de la cop27 qui va
avoir lieu à Saint-Michel ensuite il y a
un besoin de justice international et le
Sahel comme il a été si bien dit par
exemple le Sahel contribue pour les la
Banque mondiale vient de sortir un
rapport là-dessus le sale contribue pour
à peu près 1% à l'émission du gaz à
effet de serre
paradoxalement puisque on n'y a pas
d'accompagnement pour l'adaptation au
changement climatique
13,5 millions de personnes
supplémentaires vont tomber dans la
pauvreté d'ici à 2050 parce que il n'y a
pas cette justice climatique il y a pas
cet accompagnement pour que les pays
puissent s'adapter et ça je pense que
les Nations Unies ont en rôle important
de plaidoyer à jouer pour que on passe
vers une climatique donne le monde a
besoin Michel Duclos après effectivement
c'est aux états de mettre en oeuvre à la
fois cette taxe que recommande Antonio
guteres se font il a parlé d'un fond
effectivement comment vont-ils financer
ces 40 milliards les différents états à
fond justement pour aider les pays
pauvres à faire face à ce réchauffement
climatique je pense qu'il n'est
absolument pas rend fou et encore se
font
d'autre chose d'abord il y a un risque
la polarisation
politique
finissent par tuer la gouvernance
globale et donc il y a tel degré
d'hostilité entre la Chine et les
États-Unis et d'autres que on en oublie
la coopération alimentaire sur un sujet
qui nous menace tous c'est un sujet
global pareil
ensuite sur le sur le clivage Nord-Sud
moi je suis dans la tradition française
je trouve que c'est un sujet très
important et notre intérêt c'est que ce
clivage ne s'élargisse pas contraire
là je vois un risque de
d'impérialisme normatif y compris de la
part de l'Europe il faut effectivement
prévoir des moyens pour adapter et pas
seulement faire des plans sur la comète
mais adapté à quelque chose qui de toute
façon est en train d'arriver ça c'est
certain comme effectivement dans le cas
du Sahel mais il faut aussi que on fasse
attention nous que au nom de d'un combat
par ailleurs légitime on ne décrète pas
des règles qu'on va imposer à d'autres
par exemple la taxe aux frontières par
exemple dire au sénégalais il faut pas
exploiter le gaz naturel parce que le
gaz naturel c'est le mauvais pour le
crimin parce qu'à ce moment là ces pays
qui sont convaincus à juste titre que
nous avons été pendant des décennies les
plus grands pollueurs c'est nous qui
avons
la planète maintenant on arrive et on va
les empêcher de se développer au nom de
la lutte contre le changement climatique
mais la Chine utilise ce discours aussi
pour dire que
la Chine est dans la mauvaise foi
absolue bien sûr et en même temps il
faut qu'on a toujours cet espoir que sur
ce terrain-là on pourra quand même
collaborer avec elle bien sûr on a
besoin d'elle on a besoin de la Chine et
de l'Inde avant tout mais dans cette
lutte commune il faut pas qu'on perde
l'Afrique ou d'autres parce que on veut
être les mieux disons en matière
climatique donc voilà sur un plan pardon
je m'en tiens à des considérations
politiques mais c'est mon c'est mon
chrono voilà un peu le
les contraintes qui qui à mon avis
s'imposent à nous mais là en tenue du
terrestre parle de taxer justement les
pays riches enfin les énergies fossiles
des pennis pays riches il s'adresse aux
pays riches je pense que c'est une idée
à explorer parce que ce qui s'est passé
à Paris ici lors de la colle 21 c'est
que il était acquis que y compris ce que
vous venez de dire que le pays africain
est renonce à par exemple à
l'exploitation de revue fossiles mais en
contrepartie on leur verse des sommes
importantes pour accompagner cette
transformation
retrouver que c'était un marché de DIP
puisque en contrepartie l'argent n'a pas
été versé et les gens comme par exemple
quand il y a eu la covid les gens ont
préféré les urgences nationales les
urgences plutôt que de verser se font là
peut-être qu'avec cette idée de
goutteresse on pourrait alimenter ce
fond et amener l'Occident à tenir la
promesse par exemple 200 milliards de
dollars par an pour accompagner
justement le renoncement en Afrique à
une partie de son développement c'est de
ça qu'il s'agit en renonçant à certaines
énergies fossiles l'Afrique retard son
développement et en contrepartie
sécularité promis n'a pas été versé moi
je ne connais pas les je peux pas comme
ça me prononcer sur les modalités mais
je suis convaincu effectivement qu'il
faut qu'il y ait un contrat
un nouveau contrat si celui qui a été
décidé ne marche pas à nouveau contrat
entre disons le nouvel accord de Paris
une mise en oeuvre de l'accord de Paris
entre
certains l'Occident je sais pas si ça
existe mais en tous les cas entre
l'Europe ou quelques grands pays et
l'Afrique ça me paraît effectivement un
axe majeur si on
la Chine aussi bien sûr mais c'est
beaucoup plus difficile on y est arrivé
au cours des années passées il faut pas
quand tous les cas le fait que la Chine
n'y soit pas soit un prétexte pour ne
rien faire c'est ça mon point il vaut
mieux que la Chine y soit bien sûr il
faut essayer de trouver
des accords de Paris il faut avoir un
pacte mondial mais à défaut de Pacte
Mondial il faut en tous les cas faire
progresser des actions notamment euro
africaine donc des actions plus
régionales Frédéric Joly ça vous
semblerait peut-être être une solution
j'imagine que sur le terrain vous voyez
toutes ces frontières revenir ces
conflits ce nationalistes se popululisme
nationaliste d'ailleurs dont on parle
banking l'ancien secrétaire général de
l'ONU dans le monde aujourd'hui ce qu'on
voit c'est avant tout des victimes c'est
quotidien du ciel qui a pas un conflit
qui ressemble à un autre mais qu'en
revanche il y a des facteurs qui
viennent aggraver des situations qui
étaient déjà très graves et que la vraie
véritable problématique c'est de voir
que les guerres continuent comme on les
a toujours connus mais qu'aujourd'hui
par rapport au réchauffement climatique
quand on va la crise alimentaire par
exemple au sel dans la Corne de
l'Afrique je peux faire un discours de
Loris parce que heureusement il y a
plein de choses aussi qui vont bien en
Afrique mais sur certains endroits et
bien on voit que c'est vraiment pas
l'humanitaire tout seul qui réussira à
sauver les populations et avec un
doublement par exemple des enfants
malnutri en Somalie ça a doublé cette
année la période de soudure des récoltes
n'a pas été bonne
probablement aussi à venir un impact du
conflit en Ukraine sur l'arrivée des
engrais ou l'arrivée de céréales c'est
une grosse dépendance ces problèmes-là
devront être réglés par les humanitaires
au présent mais avec leur pauvres moyens
mais il faut véritablement des décisions
urgentes politiques qui visent on évite
le surcident c'est-à-dire la catastrophe
dans des situations qui étaient déjà
catastrophiques c'est du cabas donc
peut-être des accords plus régionaux
c'est ce que suggère Michel Duclos oui
je pense qu'il faut avancer entre
l'Europe et l'Afrique
globalement il faut avancer avec ceux
qui ont la volonté et de ce point de vue
il faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont l'Union européenne la Commission de
l'Union européenne a fait des
propositions madame s'est rendu au
Sénégal elle a rencontré le président
Macky Sall il y a des choses qui
commencent à bouger entre l'Europe et
l'Afrique l'enjeu c'est que l'Afrique
qui est la région la montpellante avec
moins de 4% de de mission de gaz à effet
de serre puisse avoir les
[Musique]
donc ce qui frappant c'est que
on a dit que l'Ukraine risquait
d'aggraver le clivage Nord-Sud
bizarrement parce que normalement il
devrait pas y avoir de rapport
inversement on a vu des on a vu les
États-Unis redécouvrir l'Afrique et il y
a eu cette visite de blinken alors
manifestement
c'était
on voit qu'il est pas familier du
terrain donc ici ou là il a commis des
erreurs etc mais
cette administration américaine a quand
même compris que il se passait quelque
chose que l'Afrique est appelée à jouer
un rôle important dans les équilibres du
monde et qu'il faut s'en occuper
oui c'est tout à fait exact il y a eu un
visiteur
pendant la période de Donald Trump il y
a eu une distanciation entre l'Afrique
et les États-Unis y compris au Sahel ou
Donald Trump a menacé de retirer
l'ensemble de force américaine qui était
là là avec l'arrivée de Baden on sent
qu'il y a un retour de l'Afrique et
c'est tant mieux pour la coopération
internationale donc en conclusion
finalement c'est tenu elle sert à
quelque chose ou pas Michel Duclos si on
doit conclure parce qu'on a vu que
effectivement entre la guerre en Ukraine
la régionalisation des différents
accords on multiplication des conflits
les réfugiés climatiques franchement
est-ce que c'est ce fameux machin comme
le qualifié le général de Gaulle il y a
très longtemps
quand on critique les Nations Unies on
se focalise sur le Conseil de sécurité
mais les Nations Unies ce n'est pas que
le Conseil de sécurité c'est de
multiples agences de multiples enceintes
regardez l'Ukraine
l'accord sur le blé certes la Turquie a
servi d'intermédiaire mais c'est quand
même l'ONU
qui est qui a permis l'accord ce qui se
passe avec les centrales nucléaires
c'est la IEA donc il faut pas dire que
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique
en tant que tel sont inutiles ne font
rien c'est tout simplement faux
simplement ce que font les différents
organes des Nations Unies n'est pas
toujours extrêmement visible parce qu'on
se polarise sur ce qui marche pas
les conflit quand on voit parce que là
et facilement les pays actuels
grandissent le droit de veto et ça
retarde les choses mais sur les
questions
sociales
la polarisation géopolitique j'observe
quand même qu'au Yémen il y a eu un
accord que du Représentant spécial du du
scatter général des Nations Unies
je pense à si on prend les agences
humanitaires de l'ONU si ce n'est le
Commissariat pour les réfugiés ou le
Programme alimentaire mondial vérifier
tous les jours que si elle n'était pas
là ce sera encore plus compliqué pour
les humanitaires sur le sur le terrain
et puis je pense et ça c'est
l'expérience du CICR qu'il faut toujours
se parler et que c'est une enceinte qui
est aussi faite pour ça et que le CICR
essaye d'avoir un contact confidentiel
avec tous ceux qui se battent dans les
terrains où ils travaillent et tant
qu'on arrive au moins à se parler mais
on fait probablement progresser nos
actions et cette diplomatie ras du gazon
très humanitaire du CICR mais qui je
pense tout aussi importante que celle
qui se fait à New York ou à Genève aussi
donc elle ne résout pas les conflits
elle ne prévient pas vraiment les
conflits non plus
non ça c'est un vieux rêve la prévention
des missions
ce qu'il faudra voir dans les années qui
viennent c'est une réforme peut-être les
Nations Unies oui c'est les équilibres
internes c'est à dire que les la Russie
a depuis des années fait le choix de
dynamité le système la Chine c'est plus
compliqué elle a fait le choix au
contraire de s'infiltrer et de contrôler
de plus en plus les Américains sous
Trump c'était totalement raturé
maintenant il s'aperçoivent que si ils
se retire complètement du système il
laisse la place au chinois donc dans les
années qui qui viennent on va voir se
rétablir de nouveaux équilibres ou à
nouveau ensemble d'acteurs importants
vont se réinvestir dans les dans les
Nations Unies
je pense que une des leçons de cette du
contexte d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on ne
peut pas faire l'économie d'une réforme
le cercle des pays qui exige une réforme
c'est élargie l'Afrique a pendant
longtemps à parler d'une injustice et
qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il faut réparer
aujourd'hui avec cette situation on voit
qu'on ne que le système actuel n'est pas
tenable le statico n'est pas tenable il
faut trouver les moyens de réfléchir
ensemble à une réforme qui rendent les
Nations Unies plus efficace ça sera le
mot de la fin merci beaucoup c'est du
Kaba merci Michel Duclos Merci à VOUS
Frédéric Joly merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis et vous restez avec nous
sur France 24
[Musique]